because of his young age the judge told
satanic killer daniel hussein she
couldn't jail him for the rest of his
life
as it is he'll be 54 before he gets any
chance of parole
he stalked sisters bieber henry and
nicole smallman in a park
stabbed them in a frenzy then hid their
bodies and fled
the victim's mother watched him being
sentenced
he's a broken human being
who
if he hadn't been caught
four other families
may have been suffering what we have
well he ain't out there now and i think
he is so deluded
come 35 years time
they won't give him they won't let him
out
they won't let him out
i won't let them let them out
you're under arrest just keep walking
towards me from the moment police
arrested him hussein offered no motive
for the attack and wouldn't talk to
psychiatrists who analyzed him
in his bedroom police found a contract
he'd drawn up with a demon
he promised to sacrifice six women every
six months in return he would win a huge
lottery
he signed his name in his own blood
there was evidence too of his satanic
researches
daniel hussain is a dangerous arrogant
and violent individual who from the
outset has shown no remorse or
acceptance for his actions this has been
a shocking and chilling case and i know
the investigation will stay with all of
us in bold for a very long time
hussein had explored far-right ideology
he'd spent time on a government program
to steer youngsters away from terrorism
he'd been diagnosed with autism spectrum
disorder but said the judge that didn't
explain his murders
hussein wasn't in court he appeared on a
video link from prison but he appeared
to show little interest in the hearing
he squatted on his chair turned it to
face a window and even yawned when the
judge spoke to him
she asked court staff to turn off his
camera so he can see us she said but we
don't have to see him
the sister's murder has been
controversial for several reasons the
police watchdog the iopc said the met
was too slow to begin searching for the
missing women it also said there was no
racial bias but others disagreed if this
had been a white woman who was 46 years
old celebrating her birthday no history
of going missing multiple members of the
family had said look we're very
concerned ray certainly played a part of
it
the mets commissioner apologized for the
poor response but the family said it was
too late
next week two police constables who
guarded the crime scene are due in court
charged with taking unauthorized photos
of the bodies
martin brunt sky news at the old bailey